e
mondiale prévient que le système
énergétique mondiale conduit
vers la catastrophe climatique.
- On croyait que la pandémie
de l'activité humaine avaient
permis de relâcher un peu
l'énorme pression qui pèse
sur le climat mondial.
L'Organmondialemondialemondialt
à la conclusion que
peu importe l'angle sous
lequel on observe le problème,
Gaz à erre,
niveau des mers, température
des océans, acidification
t dans le rouge.
Et les conséquences det déjàt dà
sous nos yeux, entre autres,lesr
qui affligent présentement
l'Europe et l'Asieroblèmes
moins visibles.
Certains des écarts observés
sont impressionnants.
des océans, alimentépar la font,
augmente deux fois plus vite
aujourd'hui qu'il  que
les océans continuent de
se réchauffer en profondeur,
jusqu'à 2000 mètres, ce qui
de courants irréversibles
durant des siècles.
La solution, évidemment,
passe paution
radicale des gaz à effet
de serre, le développement
et leur partage avec
moins riches.
Rappelons que les sept
dernières années ont été
les plusenregistenregistenregiss
l'ère industrielle.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-C